Zum beispiel wenn ich hier aus dem haus gehe kommen sofort ganz viele "yo alex du hast so einen brutalen körper, voll krass ich will auch so aussehen"
Das war leider noch nie so
Kurze zeit später kommt ein anderer rein
Stellt sich nicht ganz rechts anders und lässt es in der mitte frei sondern stellt sich einfach genau neben euch
Und ihr denkt euch so dicker jedoch etwa nach ganz rechts
Herzlich willkommen beim ein video ja also ich hoffe natürlich euch geht's gut ja ungefähr vor einem monat kam mein letztes jungs mädchen thema
war ein bisschen schade
das video wurde irgendwie wegen dem thumb nail
ab 18 eingestuft obwohl das thumb nail wirklich  nicht mal schlimm war deswegen weiß
Ich nicht wer von euch das alles gesehen hat ich verlinke es euch auf jeden fall
Am ende noch mal ist er doch eigentlich komplett egal
Wir machen heute schön weiter mit einem neuen thema wir haben ja gerade
Dezember unter der woche kommt jeden tag um 15 von mir ein video und am wochenende schon um 11 uhr
Und ihr könnt doch viel gewinnen das ist aber alles in meinen letzten video
läuft
Welche playstation nehmen wir?
weiß oder schwarz?
ich finde schwarz cooler
so leute
Iphone ist besteht also ich habe jetzt hier ein space grau und noch die ps4 auf jeden fall ein sehr lustiges gefühl einfach, mal
Einzukaufen und zu wissen dass es nicht für mich ist
mehr will ich gar nicht sagen wir legen sofort mal los und zwar habe ich mich
Mal wieder hingesetzt und habe überlegt über was kannst du heute reden und wahrscheinlich
Habe das auch schon am titel gelesen es geht heute um 10 geheimnisse von denen ich bis jetzt erst acht gefunden habe
Habe also zwei fehlen noch vielleicht fallen mir die im laufe des videos  ein sein ich weiß es nicht
also, zehn geheimnisse die 95 prozent aller jungs mädchen nicht erzählen
krasser titel jetzt fragt euch sicherlich ja alex wieso dann 95
94 prozent ganz einfach ich bin auf die straße gegangen, habe
1000 menschen befragt und von diesen 1000 menschen konnten wir
950 diese sache nicht nennen deswegen
95 prozent
nein spaß es können auch 90 sein aber ich finde 95 hört sich cooler an
dann würde ich jetzt aber sagen wir fangen wirklich an
ich bin
mal gespannt vielleicht schaffen wir heute wieder die 10.000 likes also für die nächsten paar
klassen nach oben da und schreibt gerne auch in die kommentare
Was ich das nächste mal reden soll und wir starten mit punkt nummer eins in der mich auch wirklich sehr sehr lange beschäftigt
Habe ich mein ich bin jetzt mittlerweile ungefähr
Habe die schuhe an habe bin ich 180 ich würde mal sagen das liegt so offen durchschnitt aber ich bin jetzt nicht so der
extrem große mensch
auch wenn viele irgendwie manchmal sagen ja in den videos kommen so viel größer als im reallife also wenn ich welche von euch auf der
Straße treffen sagen immer. Ich doch du bist größer geschrieben als er mit ihr
Könnt euch wahrscheinlich schon denken was ich meine also
vor allem somit 12 13 14 jahren wenn viele der jungs schon extrem wachsen
Manche aber noch nicht zum beispiel ich war auch wirklich in der neuen klasse war ich glaube ich gerade mal 1 55 oder
61 keine ahnung wann will als mann oder als junge eigentlich immer besonders groß
Sein und es sehr sehr oft mit seiner eigenen größe und zufrieden vor allem wenn man
Halt extrem klein ist dann gibt es ja zum beispiel auch viele leute die sich darüber lustig machen wenn sie einfach schon so groß
Und man selber erst so groß und man selber lacht. Halt immer mit aber. Im endeffekt
Ja tut das schon weh, zu wissen dass ein kleiner pisser bahn
Hält es halt irgendwie geheim und lässt es sich nicht anmerken so kommen wir zunächst eine
Sache die mir eigentlich auch ziemlich schnell eingefallen ist jetzt mal als beispiel instagram es gibt ja wirklich so viele frauen
Und mädchen die fotos von ihrer figur
Posten und da gibt es noch viel viel mehr mädchen die sich diese frauen also ich jetzt mal davon aus mädchen nehmen sich frauen als
vorbild weil diese haltung extrem schöne figur haben und wahrscheinlich denken die meisten von euch
Die jungs ist das eigentlich egal ob die jetzt so viel wie oder vielleicht so viel wiegen die haben bestimmt keine
vorbilder oder so an denen die sich körperlich
Orientieren sie ist voll kranken aber das ist ganz offensichtlich falsch es gibt auch sehr viele jungs ich würde eigentlich sagen fast alle
Die gegen wen haben
Wo die sagen die hat aber einen krassen körper so wie ich auch gern aus sind zum beispiel wenn ich hier aus dem haus gekommen
Sofort ganz will ich auch alex und brutalen körper voll costa ich auch so sehen dass
Wir da noch nie so ja das war eigentlich der zweite punkt also wir haben auch
Körperliche vorbilder so kommen wir zum nächsten punkt
Das ist das muss ich auch auf jeden fall mitnehmen
Bei, mir ist aktuell ich gehe eigentlich kaum noch feiern vor allem ich so zu dieser hip hop
musik muss dann wirklich darum geht wie heute
werden
Erklärt na ja ich sag mal, so diese klubs halt, wo die meisten leute hingehen um irgendwen kennenzulernen
Kennt man ja und dann ist es ja meistens
So dass die jungs oder sehr viele jungs die haben so das heftigste selbstbewusstsein und gehen von dieser frau
zunächst frauen machen einfach jede frau an und kriegen so einen korb nach dem anderen
Und dann sagen sie ja js juckt mich gar nicht aber. Im endeffekt
Tut das richtig weh vor allem an musste erst mal sogar seinen eigenen schatten springen und wenn man dann einen korb nach dem anderen bekommen
Also wenn euch als mädchen jemand an macht und ihr denn so richtig fetten korb gibt
könnt ihr davon ausgehen dass hat den richtig getroffen kommen wir auch schon zur nächsten sache und zwar
Gibt es ja sehr viele verschiedene lebewesen auf diesem. Planeten es gibt säugetiere es gibt
Amphibien es gibt reptilien und es gibt noch. Wohl wir sind auch säugetier wurde
Ja und all diese lebewesen haben ja irgendwelche instinkte zum beispiel eine spinne muss überleben baut ihr netz insekten fliegen rein
Spinne ist das auf die jungs zum beispiel haben auch unsere instinkte
Das ist wirklich ein instinkt das macht man ganz bewusst auch wenn man nur freuen hat und die noch so gut aussieht
man guckt halt manchmal instinktiv anderen weiblichen personen
hinterher
Das ist halt so als wenn jemand euren körper fernsteuert so mit so einem joystick die
Darum drehen obwohl man das nicht will ist auf jeden fall schwer. Zu erklären und das dann noch zuzugeben
vielleicht auch vor der eigenen freundin dass es noch schwerer sagt dann einfach ich habe ein geiles auto gesehen oder so metapher geiles auto
Brauche ich habe ein richtig geiles gerät gesehen
Er. Bezieht sich einig auf essen für uns jungs oder männer es ist wirklich extrem schwer
Frauen die wirkliche meinung die man. Hat zu ihrer figur, zu sagen
Okay, das soll es auch keinen fall oberflächlich klinge nicht meinen jede frau man kann ja gar nicht
Sagen ist ist jetzt eine frau wenn er zu dick oder zu dünn ich meine sieht ja jeder anlass für manche ist das schon zu
Dick für manche sind schon zu dünn und so weiter also das will ich jetzt gar nicht damit meinen aber wenn man jetzt zum beispiel
von einer guten freundin noch von der eigenen freundin gefragt wird ja findest du meine figur gerade cool oder nicht dass muss man
Halt irgendwie meistens geheim halten weil man ganz genau weiss man kann nicht
Sagen ja das ist gerade echt ein bisschen zu dünn oder meiner meinung nach bis zu ein bisschen zu dick
egal was man sagt
Das wäre nicht gut ich glaube die meisten trauen sich da auch gar nicht wirklich das
Zu sagen was sie denken weil man könne die personen damit verletzen
man kann sie sauer machen
Was auch immer ja das ist mir auch noch eingefallen
Das ist auch noch richtig den nächsten punkt. Habe ich irgendwo
im internet
Gefunden und zwar haben wir einen vorteil wir können ihm stehen wissen und als man tut man ja auch eigentlich mal so als könne man
Überall und neben jedem pissen wie machen will das hat sich jetzt wohl richtig an nur passt auch zum beispiel öffentliche toiletten, man
Geht auf die toilette da sind
33 ps war's oder drei pisten
nebeneinander keine ahnung wie das heißt alle drei sind frei und man geht anders ganz linke kurze zeit später kommt ein anderer rein
Stellt sich nicht ganz rechts anders und lässt es in der mitte frei sondern stellt sich einfach genau neben euch
Und ihr denkt euch so dicker jedoch etwa nach ganz rechts das ist halt irgendwie für die meisten so ein bisschen
Wenn man besoffen ist es ist scheißegal aber
Er möchte dass, im zustand so wie man
Halt meistens ist natürlich ist jetzt für manch extrem unangenehm für manche eher weniger aber so wie ich es analysiert
habe für 95
Prozent die wollen es halt nicht zugeben dass es so ist aber es ist so also können schon relativ
Glücklich sein als mädchen dass hier nur so toiletten. Habe die immerzu sind
Oder ist das doch eigentlich vielleicht gibt es ja offen
Aber diese meistens so etliche öffentliche jedoch auf
Und kommen jetzt auch schon zum letzten punkt die nicht doch analysiert habe und zwar wenn man
Jetzt junge oder als meine freundin hat und diese freundin aber auch noch sehr sehr viel kontakt hat zu anderen männlichen
personen mit denen sie wirklich nur befreundet ist oder so und euch dann zum beispiel davon erzählt jung
War letztens mit dem
Unterwegs der so und so drauf aber der ist voll cool der ist voll witzig auch wenn sich das bild an hört viele männer
5 90 prozent genau sehen das dann irgendwie so als
konkurrenz und folger irgendwie besser sein obwohl da ja gar nichts ist zwischen den person wenn ihr bestehen
Ja diesem punkt konnte ich auch herausfiltern
wollte ich euch gerne noch mitteilen und
Dann, haben wir auch schon acht stück
Das auch ganz gut ich weiß ganz genau
Ich kann das ja sogar sehen die meisten männer wollen gar nicht zugeben dass die sonne video wie ich es jetzt gerade gemacht
habt wirklich auch anschauen nur wenn ich mal meinen analytics gucken kann ich ganz genau sehen das vielleicht
65 prozent weiblich sind 35 prozent aber auch männlich und dann heißt es auch alex wie
jungs mädchen thema das gucke ich mir doch nicht an ich vergessens videos mit seinen auto oder wenn er süßigkeiten an bringt
Ja heute, so viel dass man dazu last nach
oben da
10.000 likes sind ja vielleicht drin checkt auf jeden fall die letzten videos ab auch vielleicht selbst die jungs mädchen thema wenn es noch nicht
Gesehen, habt instagram snatchers kurz eingeblendet und wir sehen uns dann schon morgen wieder um 15 uhr gibt's neues video haut rein